[Musica]
buon pomeriggio a tutti grazie di questa
opportunità che mi date cercandovi di
ascoltare su parlare di una cosa che che
seguo da molti anni e che segue tutti
voi è una molecola chimica semplice che
uno slogan americano definisce e vita e
tutto il resto non conta nulla
il punto è se è vero questo e e fino a
quando è vero ma che cos'è questa
molecola che fornisce le istruzioni a
tutte le nostre cellule di funzionare di
fare degli organi di fare degli apparati
di fare degli individui di tutte le
specie viventi che noi conosciamo sono
basate sull'informazione e questa
molecola fornisce per costruire le
proteine e tutto il resto con cui noi
svolgiamo facciamo ogni giorno una
funzione qualcosa ma è qualcosa di
veramente incredibile un mio collega
craig venter è diventato famoso
recentemente perché qualcuno va definito
l'uomo che vuole simulare dio in qualche
modo perché è costruito il primo
batterio artificiale non smontando e
rimontando dei pezzi di dna all'interno
di un sistema che hai ha ideato lui ha
definito il dna come vedete lì una
qualcosa che fornisce la musica e tutto
il resto e l'orchestra tutto il resto
intendo dire l'ambiente quello che noi
facciamo quello che noi mangiamo quello
che noi diciamo così ogni giorno
realizziamo e questa orchestra insieme
alla musica ci segue dal momento del
concepimento
quindi dal momento quando nessuno uno di
noi e potrebbe essere all'inizio un
gamete uno spermatozoo un uovo che si
fondono a fare la prima cellula 1 zygote
bene quel momento oggi è già
analizzabile per noi e lo vedete lì
sulla vostra destra cioè il dna
analizzabile l'uomo di cui ancora non
siamo niente siamo qualcosa che diverrà
poi ci segue
qualcosa che accade durante la
gravidanza e ci dà informazione di un
essere che sta sviluppandosi se sarà
sano se sarà malato se avrà delle
caratteristiche diverse da un altro oggi
questo noi lo possiamo sapere fino
quando uno nasce poi alla nascita ci dà
informazioni importanti di un bambino
che sta per svilupparsi per diventare un
piccolo adulto e lì oggi utilizziamo
questa molecola per sapere se è
portatore o meno di alcune patologie si
svilupperà o meno una patologia e si
possono fare interventi straordinari
anche a quel livello o incomincia a
crescere questa persona
intorno al al prima seconda decade di
vita ci fornisce informazioni su quelle
che sono il suo modo di diventare
qualcuno qualcosa di studiare di
comportarsi se va incontro ad ammalarsi
perché incontro un parassita un batterio
un virus
anche questo è scritto nel dna o se va
più avanti addirittura fino ad un'età
più avanzata quando incomincerà ad
aumentare il nostro rischio di
sviluppare un tumore un tumore che una
malattia terribile una persona su
quattro si ammala di cancro nel mondo
ebbene il tumore è un'anomalia del dna
non c'è dubbio su questo
in ogni tumore c'è un'alterazione del di
questa molecola del dna
oggi noi siamo in grado di leggere cosa
c'è nel tumore e addirittura sulla base
di questa lettura trovare il farmaco
giusto per guarire di quel tumore e
guarire quella persona non lo facciamo
per tutti i tumori ma per una gran parte
oggi cominciamo a capire qualcosa in più
poi naturalmente può succedere che una
persona si ammala vado in ospedale e
spesso sapete come dicevamo le r quando
parlava della chemioterapia
voi pensate che la chemioterapia è una
medicina chimica che i medici
somministrano per guarire una malattia
di cui non sanno che cos'è a una persona
che non conoscono questo è quello che io
chiamo il paradigma di molière finito
esaurito perché oggi finalmente sappiamo
e cominciamo a sviluppare il farmaco
giusto per quella persona per quel tipo
di tumore e questo lo dobbiamo grazie al
dna fino addirittura nell'età avanzata
più grande quando uno dice ma si ammala
di alzheimer o di qualcos'altro si è
possibile oggi sapere se c'è questo
rischio e come vedete addirittura oggi
c'è chi utilizza il dna per fare
un'autopsia molecolare cioè sapere di
che cosa è morta quella persona anche
dopo decenni dopo trent'anni dopo mille
anni abbiamo informazioni sul dna delle
mummie oggi per sapere di che cosa sono
morti alcuni grandi diciamo così
potremmo dire re principi o
qualcos'altro
oggi lo facciamo guardando eleggendo il
dna ma il dna ci dice anche
qualcos'altro perché alcuni popoli sono
più felice di altri al contrario o se
volete al dispetto dei problemi
economici ci sono delle variazioni
genetiche all'interno di alcune persone
quindi di alcuni gruppi che consentono
oggi di dire con una piccola variazione
e le persone che hanno questa variazione
affrontano con una maggiore sicurezza i
problemi della vita sono meno ansiosi e
vivono meglio e questo oggi lo possiamo
sapere
immaginate un futuro quando è possibile
magari aumentare questa variazione o
modificarlo leggerla quanto in problemi
di ansietà potremmo risolvere ansietà
che diventano patologiche ovviamente un
mio collega richard dawkins ha scritto
una volta in un suo bellissimo libro se
potessimo leggere il dna di un tonno o
di una stella marina troveremo scritto
all'interno mare le stupende questa
frase perché evidentemente all'interno
del dna di ognuno di noi c'è questa
informazione che viene da lontano da
miliardi di anni di questa molecola è
sulla terra da quando è sulla terra si è
evoluta si è modificata è arrivata a noi
prendendo pezzi da varie altre specie
dalle piante dai batteri dai funghi
dagli insetti dall'uomo di neanderthal
abbiamo il 23 per cento del nostro dna
che ancora risale agli uomini agli
uomini di neanderthal e far qualche
differenza
questo è molto ma molto importante
perché dobbiamo leggerlo e conoscerlo a
primi laschi ha detto beh forse
conoscerlo per salvare la nostra vita è
vero questo o non è vero
ve lo faccio con tre domande a cui oggi
possiamo finalmente rispondere tutta la
medicina moderna ma anche quella antica
è basata su queste tre domande perché
alcuni individui si ammalano più di
altri perché in alcuni un trattamento
terapeutico funziona e su altri no e
perché in alcuni dove funziona invece di
far bene fa male
ecco queste tre domande voi pensate c'è
tutta la medicina che ognuno di noi si
chiede quando apprendono a qualunque
pillola perché non sa quello che può
accadere o perlomeno non lo sapeva fino
ad oggi a questo ha risposto anche il
dna
oggi noi cominciamo a capire che ognuno
di noi è diverso
e questa variabilità e straordinaria
e incredibile è enorme poi pensate che
tra il nel mio dna e uno di voi due qui
dentro ci sono almeno 45 milioni di
differenze in termini di lettere del
codice genetico e questo è anche ci ha
permesso di dire perché non esistono più
le razze almeno dal punto di vista
biologico poi purtroppo c'è qualcuno che
le mette per altri scopi
ma dal nostro punto di vista c'è tanta
variabilità tra noi due noi tre qui
dentro e tram e un etiope ad esempio
perché grande questa variabilità e sulla
base di questa variabilità noi oggi
possiamo assicurare e fornire ad esempio
il farmaco giusto per la giusta persona
nel momento giusto e nel dosaggio giusto
questa si chiama medicina di precisione
o medicina personalizzata e non è il
futuro è oggi e questo smetteremo con
questo sistema di far danno con alcuni
farmaci
manderemo a casa vari fattucchieri vari
vari personaggi che girano che
forniscono informazioni terapeutiche
come lo sterco di capro qualcos'altro
perché sono basate sul niente non sono a
base scientifiche purtroppo lo sappiamo
come questo paese di questo c'è bisogno
per come anche in altri paesi
qualcuno dice se oggi ti diagnosticano
un cancro
la prima cosa da fare leggere il dna di
quel tumore
questo è un editoriale apparso su una
delle più grandi riviste al mondo nel
2014 e sembrano qualcosa di complicato
ma perché oggi sappiamo che leggere e
guardare nel dna del cancro
noi possiamo trovare la formula giusta
per guarire quel tumore quel cancro e
fortunatamente i farmaci che oggi
abbiamo vanno o stanno andando in questa
direzione
questo signore che vedete qui un po
invecchiato e jim watson uno dei due
scopritori del dna nel 1953 in una
grande conferenza a san diego po di
tempo fa lui ed altre persone si sono
fatto leggere tutte il dna io pure mi
sono letto tutto il mio dna ma non vi
dico quello che c'è scritto
la cosa interessante è che lui gli è
stato chiesto
ma lei dorme di notte adesso che si è
fatto leggere il suo dna
lui ha detto vi assicuro non ho perso un
minuto di sonno anzi vi dirò di più io
prima prendeva un farmaco per
l'ipertensione a 93 anni e ne prendeva
una certa dose fare i 10 15 milligrammi
al giorno qualcosa del genere e mi
creava forti capogiro mal di testa
vertigini
adesso ho capito perchè perchè nel mio
dna c'e scritto che di quel dosaggio è
sbagliato e la devo prendere molto di
meno
infatti ho cambiato la dose e sto
benissimo
c'è un'altra informazione che ho trovato
nel mio dna dice jim watson
e il fatto che hanno trovato io c'ho un
gene di predisposizione al tumore della
mammella ma ciò 93 anni sono maschio
potrebbe non essere utile ma attenzione
è molto importante non per me ma per i
miei figli a cui ho fornito questa
informazione e faranno il test ea loro
quel test di serve servirà moltissimo
un test del dna oggi deve essere fatto
in maniera precisa accurata nel posto
giusto nel momento giusto con
l'informazione giusta non si può fare
via internet non si può mandare un
campione di saliva e poi magari viene
analizzato nel wisconsin e non sapete
che fine fa quel dna perché come ha
detto anche lui il dna è una molecola
straordinaria perché trasmette
istruzioni per costruire gli esseri
umani e questa è una frase bellissima
dei ci pensate
guardate che attraverso il dna si
identificano le persone si scoprono gli
assassini si fa tutto oggi non c'è
giorno in cui diciamo da tutti i punti
di vista dei media dei giornali non
ascoltate questa magica parola è scritto
nel dna
in effetti è vero nel dna c'e tanto c'è
molto e noi dobbiamo cominciando oggi ad
imparare a conviverci con questo senza
averne paura perché c'è un solo modo per
sconfiggere la paura e la conoscenza nel
momento in cui noi conosciamo
conosciamo il nostro genoma conosciamo
il nostro dna
immediatamente abbiamo gli strumenti per
uscire dalle paure di ammalarci dalle
paure di non guarire dalle paura di
essere in qualche modo schedati come
dice qualcuno invece le schedature come
voi sapete accadono più per altre
ragioni che non per il dna e di questo
noi dobbiamo avere oggi la
consapevolezza che questa molecola
straordinaria sarà sempre a fianco è
sempre vicino a noi è sempre di più
coinvolgerà la nostro modo di vivere di
pensare di essere
grazie
[Applauso]